there hasn't been a mafia trial on this
scale for more than 30
years hundreds of defendants from the
andanga crime organization prosecuted
together in a cavernous high security
bunker in the midst of their Mafia
Heartland of Calabria it took more than
an hour and a half to read out the
verdicts a crucial factor in the
prosecution case was the more than 50
mafia members who became prosecution
witnesses
certainly that cruel violent and ongoing
part of the Inda which has sown fear for
decades is impacted there is a strong
message that civil society and
especially those entrepreneurs and Shop
owners who are still being crushed by
the inanga that they can trust the state
this is certainly the most important
message coming out of this verdict the
andanga has established a near Monopoly
control of illegal cocaine Imports to
Europe combined with brutal murders
extortion corrupt ition of public
contracts and a kaleidoscope of moneya
laundering Investments its criminal
proceeds are estimated at around 53
billion doar a year andanga defendants
had nicknames Like the Wolf fatty and
lamp thigh but prosecutors also wearn
for many non- mafia members including a
high- ranking police official local
Mayors and other public figures and
businessmen who'd willingly facilitated
the mob's
activities 131 defendants were acquitted
by the judges and crime experts point
out that this trial focused primarily on
the manuso clan leaving much of the
anda's other Clan bosses untouched but
putting more than 200 people behind bars
is still a major boost for law
enforcement Paul Brennan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer